[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning it's
been a very tough week on capitol hill
where four police officers caught up in
the mob violence on january 6th
testified in very graphic detail about
what they experienced
pictures still get to you that includes
capitol police officer harry dunn
who talked with nicole killian about the
impact of the attack on him
and his family and what he wants to see
from the congressional investigation
nicole good morning my heart broke
listening to all the officers but
harry dunn in particular really got to
me how's he doing
well gail officer dunn told me that he
felt
every range of emotion when he testified
from
anger to hope and he says that since his
appearance on capitol hill this week
he's received an
outpouring of support but also attacks
especially
on social media you swear i affirmed
you heard four stories four stories from
january 6.
there were hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of more stories
that need to be and could be there could
be a need to be told
u.s capitol police officer harry dunn
says he's been getting disparaging
messages
ever since his testimony before the
house select committee
investigating january 6th so many people
were so proud of you were so proud of
you and
then here come the naysayers and the
negative nazis and
people are saying i've been bought and
paid off and
how much did you sell out for you are a
coward you're a traitor
you're not an amer you're not a real
police officer and then that just kind
of
took me to a
low place he hasn't gotten any death
threats like metropolitan police officer
mike fanon
who received one while he was testifying
i wish they would have killed all you
scumbags
what do you make of that message so i
had to talk to him about it because i
it makes me so upset but the 13-year
veteran of the force said it's
no worse than when rioters hurled racial
slurs at him during the capital attack
it was almost just as hurtful like
because i pride myself on my credibility
my integrity and my honor like i'm not
getting
anything out of this it has been an
isolating experience for dunn
who often works six days a week while
also
juggling therapy it's lonely doing this
thing that's why me and mike have
i believe such a strong relationship we
have the same
goal in mind and that's about
accountability and justice
and the truth even at the highest levels
there was an attack carried out on
january 6
and a hit man sent them who were you
talking about
there was a rally prior to the attack
it was a rally those facts exist
um there were quotes said like we got to
fight like hell
or you won't have a country left are you
talking about the former president those
were his words
do you think the former president should
testify
that's their that's their job i don't
know perhaps the hardest testimony dunn
has to give
is to his own nine-year-old daughter
what have you told her about all of this
uh you got to try to you know shield
your kids
from his uh but you also want to be
honest with them
and um i literally just say some bad
people
try to do some bad things to the capitol
and to the country
and uh the good guys won so
i mean how is she processing it i can
tell that uh
she hugs me a little tighter um she has
me a little longer
and uh god i love those hugs
you know they're amazing so i don't i
oblige
her as long as she wants officer
dunn's daughter was not at the hearing
but some of his family was he says he is
optimistic about
the select committee and would be
willing to testify again
even if republicans break out and launch
their own
investigation he also hasn't given up on
an independent 9 11 style panel anything
to get to the root causes of what
happened nicole thank you so much
and that was great reporting i don't
know how anybody could look at that
video
whether you're a republican or a
democrat and not
want to hear or understand the relevance
of those
officers who were there that day and
harry harry dunn's daughter's hugs make
up for a lot but he should not have to
go he went through enough on january 6.
he should not have to go through what
people are doing today all of them did
and then you see the
the voicemail that michael fanon got the
fact that these guys are getting any
kind of criticism after they risk their
lives
to save the people that are now
criticizing them it's just mind-boggling
to me i
applaud them all for speaking up the way
that they under the worst circumstances
they were protecting
the capital they were protecting the
congress and they were protecting
the constitution and harry done alluded
to it there is still a lot of officers
off the job that we don't hear about yes
that are still suffering that day and
he's right officer done accountability
justice
and the truth is what everybody those
are just four of the stories
exactly right